[Music]
so a texas man has been arrested after
storing his son's dead body in his
kitchen since 2018. kitchen texas man
why do you do that that's what you got
from that texas it sounded like a
superhero
killed his son and put him in his fridge
does he have a big [ __ ] belt buckle
and a cowboy hat in his fridge for four
years texas and then he's and he's being
arrested taking the car in his texas man
costume and the little kid's like saying
so texas man
yeah son i killed my son
he's in my fridge yes son i killed my
son
the second [ __ ] he's like
texas man
what's the superpower what's the way to
immediately make a joke about a death
guy's genius making light how
insensitive ryan
two seconds all right let's take a
picture of what let's imagine what texas
man looks like big [ __ ] cowboy hat
right big [ __ ] belt buckle the
[ __ ] state of michelob in his hand
he's a big dude he has to be a big guy
extremely leather belt extremely
extremely well sitting on a [ __ ] the
long horn [ __ ] thing oh yeah he's got
a long horde here and a longhorn here
bro and a longhorn mustache
and his t-shirt says free mustache rides
cause he's funny he's a funny he's got
he's got some friends he's like the
deadpool it has a tattoo of a revolver
on his
penis whoa
[ __ ]
that extends to a shotgun when he gets a
boner oh whoa
barrel
truck nuts trunk nuts oh yeah truck nuts
big [ __ ] big rig you got another
mustache right here tattooed so you can
go like this oh cover the big the big
one
that's the austin texas guy the mustache
oh yeah awesome that's hipster that's
him that's his nemesis is
[Laughter]
ass beer dude who cares [ __ ] beer get
a nickel up get a [ __ ] corona how
could you texas man texas man
did his son die of natural causes uh
they're they're not saying they believe
that his son died in 2018 um and he is
being charged with abuse of a corpse
um due to the storing of it in a
domicile due to the story i could try to
empathize here we go maybe
maybe his son died
of natural causes but he feels so sad
and he misses him that yeah he's like
i'm a star this dude so that's what i
want to talk about right so like trauma
bro
these these guys really don't
you don't want to let go of the sun
why'd you give me an asian father good
yeah yeah they don't know
they don't know the cause of death he's
being taken for an autopsy now but it
was he was largely skeletal
um
and so obviously he wasn't preserved
very well but right i was like dude if
he's frozen shouldn't he not be as
skeletal you would think was he was he
frozen was you know he's just chilling
in the kitchen oh he's chilling in the
kitchen like decomposing bars oh he's
like sitting at his kitchen table
oh
yeah
i did that huh which part of me let me
elaborate which part did you do
all right let me elaborate
you said a kitchen table right i could
empathize with how he felt with about
his child
because my friend he got a baby sparrow
right he used to shake the [ __ ] out of
these street signs because um in gardena
the street signs they had holes in it
and then they would do bird nests right
so he thought it was funny to shake him
and then he would stand there with
[ __ ] ralph's bags right these grocery
bags and when the birds fly out he would
just go like this like a net and grab
him
right so he would grab them but
sometimes baby sparrows who can't even
fly it will fly down and then
at first [ __ ] eggshells would be
cracking [ __ ] birds and [ __ ] dropping
and he felt lord so he he [ __ ] comes
over with a grocery bag full of birds
and [ __ ] that are like not moving and
i'm like all right what are you gonna do
with things you want one and i'm like
[ __ ] yeah i want a bird this is like
what third grade or whatever
can i get a bird you want a not moving
bird
no i get a baby bird that's still alive
okay oh
you're like i don't want that one that
was not moving
that was not moving in bart's defense
you did set that up horribly
[Laughter]
i was like there's a bag of dead birds
thinking of the movie once
some of them weren't
i was like give me the one that's
actually moving okay okay
i take that [ __ ] cute little chick
right
[ __ ] hops around every day i can't
wait to go home from school so i can
feed it some [ __ ] bread and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] tries to fly away i grab
that [ __ ] no you don't you're my baby
right
one day
[ __ ] dies
i think it's the first time i had a pet
die on me man that [ __ ] was [ __ ] so
sad so me and my mom we went to the you
know front yard we had this whole bush
area she goes we're gonna give it a
[ __ ] funeral and i'm like all right
dig it up bury it
next day in school
that's all i think about this
[ __ ] dying right and then my uh
parents brainwashed me into christianity
and i always had this image of you know
when god comes the [ __ ] everybody
gets out of the grave and then they come
back right and i'm like looks like
thriller but good good thriller right
and i'm like wait
and i had it in my head
that if this [ __ ] if jesus comes
this bird is gonna be decomposed like a
[ __ ] i gotta mummify this [ __ ]
right so i'm like [ __ ] i'd even put it
in a coffin right yeah so as soon as i
get home
grab a [ __ ] ziploc bag
dig the [ __ ] up he's still fresh all
right tight right throw it in a [ __ ]
plastic bag zip it up bury them all
right proper burial if jesus comes we're
going to resurrect this [ __ ] jesus
comes he comes up and he's in the
plastic bag he can't believe it
i was in third grade goddammit god's
grave doesn't no heaven's right there
the ziplock is so good and then i feel
better about it i'm like all right
when jesus comes
it's all good man [ __ ] because
plastic bags they save everything they
say food leftovers let's go right
my mom is doing the like garden and she
[ __ ]
she digs up the plastic back with a dead
ass bird and she comes up to me she goes
what the [ __ ] is this
how long ago was it how long after
i don't remember but i remember getting
in deep [ __ ] she goes why did you do
this where he buried him like i was
[ __ ] i was so shocked i was doing the
garden and [ __ ] and then this thing pops
up did you explain yourself because you
had such good rationale yeah
yeah i i think i did i mean if it's god
based i said yeah
well for a third grader to think that
deeply of like the body's not going to
decompose properly yeah i don't think i
would get mad if i saw that i wonder why
your mom got mad or make sure there's
free fighters with a ziploc no i think i
[ __ ] up the garden like i think i dug
everywhere
you know like third grade yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's just like oh yeah where's that bird
again digs up everything i probably did
so i remember i left it with a couple of
plants and roses
yo oh yeah and i i grabbed all the
flowers and i put it on top and [ __ ]
like i relocated everything okay so i
probably [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
i know she was mad about how much i
[ __ ] it up rather than that but i told
her my [ __ ] we [ __ ] cried together
and then i was like but i want it back
and then that feeling of like i want to
preserve it
i if that's his kid he's gonna have a
giant ziploc bag and save that [ __ ] he
should have because he's gonna wait for
jesus to come back
the whole time he's away for jesus
well that's not what the egyptians
believed about the pharaohs and [ __ ]
like that you gotta preserve them so
that they can yeah they believe that
jesus was gonna come back so
he's like we need ziploc we need to
create but jesus comes back is all i
didn't have plastic in my day i don't
know how to deal with that yeah that's
on you dog how does that open just like
normally or
yeah christmas was pretty sick back then
i heard
uh no so would you guys would you guys i
mean is this something that because i
think i have a problem with letting go
of things but i i can't say that i um i
know how i would deal with like a major
family member's death like other than my
even my grandfather i still think about
it all the [ __ ] time so it's like
you're tight with their grandpa oh yeah
who's the man i think these days we have
better technology so you could get that
whole vacuum seal thing where you put
the plastic on both sides of the body
and you can preserve it better you turn
on the vacuum and it goes
yeah
yeah and then you can souven it later
and then you can see
like this against the plastic bag and
they're like keys preserved
and then when jesus comes back
everyone's like getting out of their
coffin and [ __ ] and his [ __ ]
like i can't get out man what the [ __ ]
he dies again
they were wrong
during the coming back everyone was
wrong
that's it there's nowhere else to go
[Music]